instead of going to their factories or
offices tens of thousands of belgians
take to the streets unable to cope with
dramatic price hikes they hope to send a
strong message to their government
everything is getting more expensive
fuel products in the shops life is
getting very hard people can't accept
this any longer
the nationwide strike forced brussels
airport to cancel all departing flights
after its security personnel joined the
protest
like in other european countries
inflation has reached more than 8
percent in belgium the highest in nearly
40 years
rising energy prices due to the war in
ukraine and the political fallout in
europe have caused prices of basic goods
to go up as well
i'm playing a millionaire to show that
they have enough of everything while
these people here have to live off a
small wage and while prices have gone up
significantly the belgian government
still wants to hold on to the wage act
the wage standard act adopted in 1996
allows the government to put a cap on
salary increases every two years to make
sure wages remain competitive with
neighboring countries despite rising
prices belgian workers will this year
receive a salary increase of 0.4 percent
unacceptable according to the country's
labor unions when i go and
buy
a bread it cost 1 euro 60 a few months
ago now it costs 2 euro 20 that's 60
cents of
price increase but the indexation system
we have doesn't follow this price
increase so you still are buying the
same bread but you don't have a uh
increase of your wage and it's your it's
the work of the people that create the
wealth in this country and they should
the rich the rich the the perfective
there's wealth in this country should be
distributed to the people too
this could be the start of a long hot
summer according to these protesters if
their demands are not met more strikes
will likely follow and this action today
has already led to chaotic scenes around
the country
airport personnel pilots and cabin crew
at brussels airport have announced more
strikes later this week workers in the
other sectors are waiting for a
government response before deciding
whether to take more action step faster
than al jazeera in brussels